with temperatures falling and winter on
the way our next guests have written a
story that aims to warm readers Hearts
Angie Thomas and Danielle Clayton are
two of the six authors behind white out
the novel is a celebration of black joy
and Young Love in snowy Atlanta it's a
follow-up to their New York Times
bestseller blackout we spoke with
authors last year about the novel take a
look
one thing that blackout does and it does
beautifully is that it affirms to black
kids that you can be the center of the
love story and we're telling them over
and over again that their lives matter
but we're telling them in the context of
trauma and I think that by showing
various kinds of love stories it really
brings that message home that your lives
matter your dreams matter your love
matters your hope matters all of it all
of it matters I think we're like the
Captain Planet
all of our forces combined because now
created this wonderful experience that
as we move through the city and move
through the stories and meet the
characters it comes alive
Angie Thomas and Daniel Clayton joins us
right now good morning how are you doing
good morning all right so Danielle how
did the idea for white out come about
well I was talking to my niece who's 16
and she kept saying why don't black
girls get to be the center of love
stories and film and TV and she was
really upset about it and we thought
whoa that's right and so we did blackout
which is heat and then we have a couple
of Christmas Queens okay that are part
of our six you know what I mean six so
we thought black people in the snow
super cute
and super super unusual
but Angie I'm fascinated by all of you
authors together how do you decide who's
going to write what because there's six
of you yeah how do you divide up what
well you know we call them leadership
skills that Danielle here has she
basically came to us and she said you
know what we have there are these tropes
in literature yeah they're so often used
like you know best friends to lovers
blah blah blah but we rarely get to see
see black kids in these tropes so she's
like I'm gonna sign you a Trope and I
want you to use that and write that
story
you know when you're really jealous some
of the tropes well we have enemies to
lovers uh best friends to lovers what's
another one a triangle triangle and the
big one is the grovel right it's like a
gravel a second chance
you kind of messed up and you got a
gravel yeah you got a gravel you gotta
correct and there's some big groveling
this yes I love that you said it's a
love story that feels like a big
glorious puzzle because sometimes
falling in love feels like a puzzle
isn't that good yeah and it's true and
it's hard and when you're a teenager and
you have all of these feelings yes
trying to figure out how to talk about
those feelings and have the courage to
love it's really hard you're you're a
puzzle yourself so we wanted to make the
book feel like a puzzle of many
different kinds of love stories and one
big messy Love Story it does deal with
serious topics like sexual identity
mental health how do you know navigate
those story lines so that they resonate
with readers well I think the main thing
is as young adult authors we respect our
readers we respect what they're going
through we respect their struggles we
respect their triumphs and we listen to
them and in writing for them I think
that's the most important thing you have
to do so we're also talking about you
know young people who are dealing with
things we've all dealt with you know
anxiety and and all of these things
we've dealt with these so we're going
from our own experiences as well and
showing that hey here characters who
look like you who are going through
these same things and hopefully
normalizing it for them a little more
there's a great scene in the book that I
cracked up it's Omarion Jordan and
they're in the car and they're driving
and everybody knows if you're driving
you have control of the radio everybody
everybody knows he kept changing the
radius no Jordan was driving and she was
very upset and then he changed on a
Beyonce you did not do that she's very
angry absolutely and so is that that's
how people get cut that's exactly right
so I was wondering how much of it you
drew from your own personal experiences
but I thought something like that is so
relatable and so true and you're writing
in teenage voices and no disrespect
neither one of y'alls we are not but you
look it we're saying you they'll spring
chickens but because we love and respect
the kids that we're writing for the
teams that we're writing for we want to
honor their experiences I was a teacher
for 13 years I'm writing for my students
in East Harlem and also I'm remembering
myself at 16. I was a mess I didn't have
the courageous
I was more like hate hate hate ooh I
like I like I like oh no I'm in love so
that's like probably what I'm like as an
adult too but like yeah that's her as an
adult yeah it's hard to tell someone you
love them and so we wanted to really
sort of Channel our teenage selves yeah
but also the teenagers that we work with
that we see across the country honor
those experiences it's messy Angie
according to pen America books involving
lgbtq themes are being banned more and
more what's your message to those that
are making it harder for books like
these to hit the shelves and reach young
readers yeah books featuring lgbtqia
plus characters books featuring black
characters you know my books are some of
the top 10 most banned books in the
country and I think what I wish people
would think about is the message that is
sending to the kids who see themselves
in these stories you know we're writing
mirrors and for them and they see
themselves in these characters and when
you're saying ban this book what you're
essentially saying is you make me
uncomfortable I don't want to hear from
you what I wish more people would do is
talk to to the kids who were reading
these books who see themselves in these
books and ask them how has this impacted
you I have yet to have a kid tell me the
hate you give made them feel bad for who
they are right you know if nothing else
it's opened their eyes and expanded the
world for them and there's nothing wrong
and it's empowering thank you Andrew
Thomas Daniel Clayton thank you so much
congrats white out it's on sale now